Speaker 1: I want to briefly play a clip for
you. This maybe is a little bit different
than what we typically do, although not. Not
really. There's this band called Staind without
an e t A&E and stains. Lead singer is Aaron
Lewis. And I've actually had run-ins with
with this band because they are from western
Massachusetts, the area where I grew up. As
many of you know, I worked at Circuit City
in Holyoke, Massachusetts, when I was in high
school, and the band would often come in to
buy, you know, equipment, equipment they needed
for a recording or their home studios or whatever
they were around. They were kind of known
entities and over the last I, it hasn't even
really been recent at least ten years, if
not longer. The lead singer, Aaron Lewis,
has sort of devolved into some pretty unsophisticated
right wing notary, and I was quite shocked
to see a clip of him. I guess he's doing performances.
This is from just a few days ago where he
was almost in like a conspiracy coma. Just
everything he said made no sense whatsoever.
And one of the scary things is the crowd is
cheering at some of the stuff he's saying.
So listen to this. This is really, really
bad.
Speaker 5: You know, it's, you know, this
is sound. Maybe we should listen to what Vladimir
Putin is saying
Speaker 1: now, why? Why are people cheering
about that? Yes. Cheer to listen to Putin.
What?
Speaker 5: Maybe, just maybe when Klaus Schwab
and George Soros and every other dirty earth
destroying mother.
Speaker 1: So he's listing Jewish men and
calling them dirty. And I know it's not overtly
anti-Semitic, but when you start talking deep
state and conspiracies and you start naming
Jewish men and start using the adjective dirty
it, it's either anti-Semitic or it comes from
an anti-Semitic framework. And we know that
that to be the case with frequency
Speaker 5: jumps on the same bandwagon. Maybe,
just maybe, we should take a good look at
that. Why are they trying to protect Ukraine
so
Speaker 1: much because Putin is invading
it for absolutely no legitimate reason would
be a start.
Speaker 5: They all have to lose. So, so
Speaker 1: a very pro-Putin crowd at Aaron
Lewis's acoustic show.
Speaker 5: I mean, have you seen the pictures
with wooden guns and ammo and all the bodies
and body bags laying in the background and
moving to one of the bodies that are moving
in there since I've been six? This is my bag.
Well, well, the well, the the the person and
this reporter is reporting.
Speaker 1: He barely has any idea what he's
talking about, but he is repeating some conspiracy
theories that have been floating around people.
Speaker 5: If you haven't seen that, you'd
better start looking elsewhere. If you haven't
seen Vladimir Putin actually say that he is
fighting the deep state right now, which is
the same people we're fighting, which is the
same people everywhere in the face of this
Earth that people are fighting.
Speaker 1: We're all united against the deep
state. So, you know, many of you know that
one of the really common things that the right
likes to do with athletes and entertainers
is when you don't like their politics, right?
When it's LeBron James or Colin Kaepernick
or Jon Bon Jovi or I'm trying to think what
other? What other? Bruce Springsteen, when
you don't like their politics, it's shut up
and dribble. Shut up and sing and play guitar.
I didn't pay for you to give me your political
views or whatever, but when they like the
substance, it's whoa. Wait a second. We we
can't suppress the free speech of these people
even saying you respect their right to say
it, but you don't agree that that's a suppression
on speech. Now, as I've said before, I try
to have a consistent view on this, and my
view is anyone who has a platform of any kind,
even if it's because you're good at a sport
or because you're good at singing or because
you're in movies, whatever. If you have a
platform, you have every right to use that
platform. However, the hell you want and others
can decide on that basis whether they want
to give you their money. If you are an athlete
and you want to talk about politics have at
it. I 100 percent support people doing that.
If I don't like what you say, maybe I choose
not to go to your games. It's just my choice.
And maybe if I do like what you say, I choose
to go. Steve Nash, a former basketball player.
I believe he's now a coach Canadian and would
often comment on politics and people say,
Oh, he shouldn't be talking. No. Let him say
what? Don't go to the games. Don't go to the
games if you don't like him. Bruce Springsteen,
known for his little kind of political raps
to the crowd in between songs. If you don't
like it, don't go. It's that simple. Green
Day, a band I liked growing up would often
make in the bush era anti-war anti-Iraq war
statements. You bought a ticket. During the
during the concert, you may see melodies played
that you do or don't like. You may hear the
lyrics that you like or don't like, and you
may hear political statements that you like
or don't like. Use all of that to make a decision
as to whether you want to give your forty
five bucks or whatever it was at the time
to Green Day. And that's absolutely fine.
But these these blankets, they shut up and
dribble play guitar or don't. It's sort of
like when information is leaked. And now both
Democrats and Republicans do this when you
have a leak of information. Often elected
officials, if they like the substance, they'll
only talk about the substance and not how
it was obtained. And if they don't like the
substance, they'll ignore the substance. But
talk about, Wow, this really shouldn't have
been released. It's a similar thing with a
lot of these right wingers on the athletes,
celebrities and musicians commenting on politics,
I say, Say whatever you want. I'll decide
whether I want to patronize your business
or not. And it's that simple.